you love posting threads of ugly
psychology truths on the internet I love
learning about them and then we get to
talk about them on the show So today
we're going to go through as many as we
can the first one which I thought was
fascinating women think that having sex
with a man on the first date will bond
him to her but that doesn't work with
secure men or avoidant men it really
only works with crushingly insecure men
who crave approval and women don't want
to bond with those men
men we don't we don't get the same kind
of hormone release that women do and we
don't process it the same for us it's a
lot more dopamine it's not the same
level of oxytocin quite that they get so
we are very different women if they have
an orgasm with a man they're probably
going to bond with him this is why
casual sex is so so difficult for women
and especially maintaining friendships
um and just steady platonic or casual
friends with benefit situations for
women this is why they turn Friends with
Benefits into situationships this is why
this happens they will start off
agreeing one thing then do the other
you've probably seen this before I'm
sure
um men don't bond that way they don't
they just don't typically if there's
already a bond happening yes then having
sex can be unitive and it can make him
love you and and and not love you but
make him care for you more it can
increase his affection for you it can
increase the bonding but the connection
already has to be there you don't get a
guy to fall in love with you doing that
so this whole first date sleep with them
on the first date so he'll stay around
that's a whole other thing
yeah I wonder whether it's women using
their theory of mind I think in The
evolutionary psychology literature it's
called cross-sex mind reading failures
so
um they believe that
if it was me
the only way that I would be able to
sleep with somebody is if I felt very
deeply about them therefore if this
happens with the man then this is how he
must feel about me and it's a failure of
of using your own theory of mind you're
very right it's also I've been studying
a lot into mirroring neurons especially
when we're little children so when we're
born we have the amygdala and then we
have a lot of mirroring neurons it's two
of the only structures that are really
fully formed at Birth and are mirroring
neurons we're supposed to have mom mom
is supposed to be paying attention to us
and and looking at us and mirroring our
expression to her so that we we feel
interesting to people just by existing
and then when we make a face she mirrors
it back to us and we start mirroring
each other and we say other people will
respond to me I am enough if Mom doesn't
she's depressed she's tired she's
exhausted she's working three jobs and
is never there we're in daycare all the
time if we've had NICU trauma if we've
had various issues our brain says mom is
not mirroring me or or I can't get a
response I have to be interesting to get
Mom's attention this is where kids start
acting out a lot or they go Inward and
don't believe they can get any kind of
response the response tries to dies the
desire to even connect so then people
are trying in dating to be interesting
they're trying to stimulate late others
women say I have to sleep with them on
the first date or he'll lose interest
when you hear that her mother probably
didn't mirror with her correctly her
father didn't mirror with her correctly
she learned I have to be interesting and
stimulating guys same thing when they
try to dance for women's approval it's
that mirroring neurons all the way back
have you you've probably met guys like
this right that try to be interesting
instead of be real
yeah I think there's a a massive lack of
confidence and insecurity around
authenticity there's all manner of rumor
and half truth and full truth and no
truth about vulnerability and when it's
right to open up and when you shouldn't
open up as a man and you know the more
layers of of Bro Science and and half
remembered hearsay that you layer on top
of an interaction the more performative
it becomes the more Persona and less
person there is in the interaction and
the more that that happens the less you
actually feel connected with what you're
doing because you're not connecting from
you to a person you're playing a role so
even if you do get the outcome that you
want the person isn't in love with you
they're in love with this projection
that you've given them and you know this
is such a it's such a dangerous
Catch-22 to fall into it's the reason I
think fundamentally that the actual
hardcore pickup World failed for men
that were unconfident with women because
what it taught them was that the person
they had to be and the person that they
genuinely were
so far apart if I need to go through
this massive rigmarole and say did you
see the fight with two midgets outside
isn't that and then I've got a neggar
and like twist the lemon and I've got to
like you know ignore her and chat up her
friend and do all this [__] it's like if
I have to go through this complex
[__] rain dance to try and get a
woman to go to bed with me
and that's not what I would do what does
that say about me and absolutely you
know it's one of the problems of taking
your cues from culture as opposed from
yourself and again you know a lot of
this could come from parenting problems
too it is think of this there's from
from what I have found there are two
different dating pools and they don't
flag or signal to each other at all they
have almost no crossover they're not
even aware of each other there's a
secure people who want that direct human
authentic connection of we are together
we are talking we're sharing this Bond
they don't want stimulation because it
feels weird too much stimulation up
front feels weird to them they
understand that connection so they want
the right bonding experience then
there's the insecure pool that everybody
is trying to be interesting interesting
interesting and they're playing that
anxious or that avoidant dance over here
two different pools that never cross so
when you see guys every woman out there
expects you to be eight feet tall and
have an 18 inch dick and you have to
have 10 billion in the bank and no no
you don't and you don't have to dance
for her amusement and endlessly play
games or have dread game or control her
that's only going to work on those
insecure women over here it's never
going to work on secure women they will
get up and walk away you're going to
look confusing to them or disinterested
and they're going to track as confusing
or disinterested for you the two dating
pools are segregated out completely
according to this model it is wild to
see
yeah and you know just to kind of round
out the women having sex on a first date
thinking that it'll get a man to bond
with her
I I
I really really don't think that many of
the girls that listen to the show will
think that but if there is or if you've
got a friend that does think that like
price is an indicator of quality
and for almost all of human history
there was a courting period that needed
to occur even if the courting period was
passive because you lived in the same
tribe together and she observed you
being competent and reliable and
trustworthy and bringing back a big
wildebeest and helping out with the
whatever whatever right so there is a
period of of value uh justification from
man to woman and also from woman to man
and if you shortcut that the presumption
from a lot of guys and I can tell you
this from first and second hand
experience if a woman gives it up too
easily the assumption is well she'll do
this to any man
correct that's that's the first thing
men think of that was a great hamburger
everyone is eating this hamburger I'll
come back when I'm hungry but it's not
the hamburger I'm gonna sell for
[__] yeah all right next one a person
obsessing over politics is a good
indicator that their personal
relationships are a mess unless they're
financially invested in the political
sphere they're probably compensating for
feeling powerless in their life
if you're looking for someone to save
you they're not going to save you number
one and you need to actually do the work
in your own life are there things that
impact you yeah there are should you be
completely obsessed with finding the
right person who's going to save you and
all of society nah Chris how many people
have you met that are obsessed with
politics to a degree that they're not
really involved in them it's their sport
yeah quite a few
Twitter right I mean that's that's a
large part of what drives Twitter's
business is arguing over who is going to
save us best and who should be the enemy
and who we outside and who we Exile and
if if they're doing that that's not done
by people who are happy let's say it
another way the happiest people are not
on social media yelling about politics
they might be on social media posting
about their kids or they're going to be
out with their kids or their family or
their best friends they're going to be
building a life they have so much more
to do than just politics and they just
navigate around the politics that are
happening
so you think that it's a compensatory
mechanism
every single time I have seen someone
come into my therapy office or now my
coaching and start talking to me
endlessly about this is so important
this person and this I say okay let's
steer it back to your life they will
steer it away from their life back into
politics because they think that they
are showing who they are by by following
the right things and having the right
politics and they think that that gives
them value and it also makes them feel
safe because they can talk about it and
again they're trying to be interesting
they're trying to stimulate they're not
even having a real conversation they're
not discussing it it is just a
compensation in every capacity and they
will not talk about the gaps in their
own life they want to run away from that
I wonder if a little bit of it is
externalizing the locus of control that
look my life isn't where I want it to be
my relationships aren't where I want
them to be
and it's the fault of whatever's going
on outside it's the economy it's because
of social media it's because of Silicon
Valley it's because of immigration or
the war in Ukraine or the price of
pharmaceuticals or estrogens in the
water like
putting the blame outward onto something
that you kind of know that you can't
impact
is is actually a really perverse type of
victim mentality because you know that
you're not going to stop estrogens from
getting into the water you know that
you're not going to change the war in
the Ukraine this isn't to say that you
can't have an issue with this you can't
be aware of this you can't campaign for
it and make changes for it but if it is
the fundamental driving force in a life
where you feel powerless and you point
the finger of blame that is the
equivalent of pointing the finger of
power you say the Ukraine that's what
has all of the power over my
relationships and my mood the the
economy that's what has all of it and
these things were not separate from
these things but absolutely there is
I feel like there is a non-insignificant
cohort of people who use Politics as an
excuse to not engage properly with the
challenges that they're facing in their
life absolutely if someone bring I'm not
saying that the political pieces aren't
a problem yeah the economy sucks yeah it
does but here's the real test is when
someone is complaining about a political
thing ask them okay what are you going
to do about it what are you going to do
about it if they have an answer they are
taking control in their personal life if
their answer is we have to elect so and
so they will save us or we have to shoot
the other side in the head or if that's
their answer no that's not going to help
them in any way shape or form they don't
actually have any control like you locus
of control you nailed it I love that
their locus of control is externalized
and they are hoping someone will save
them it's it's very much the same of
watching a sports team and saying when
the sports team wins they say we won
it's exactly the same thing
um right next one people are more likely
to take a pill for years that they don't
understand and don't think will actually
help them then they are to attempt even
one uncomfortable conversation that
could save their life
people number one will trust
institutions blindly because there's
that locus of control this doctor will
save me this doctor said this medication
will save me it will make me feel better
sometimes the placebo effect works for
that and that's scary
um people don't want to do the work
though because the work is exhausting
the work takes willpower the work takes
hope taking a pill doesn't take hope you
just have to put it in your mouth and
swallow it and you can just see how it
works in six weeks
doing the work is hard and when they
don't feel that they can affect change
and they don't feel that they can
actually make anything happen so work is
pointless work is scary work will just
confirm for them that they're helpless
so they don't want to do the work they
don't want to have the conversation
pill is easier how how many times have
you seen somebody come into your
practice that is sort of one difficult
conversation away from a radically
different life
that is pretty much every person who
comes into my office and my coaching
session is
what conversation are you too terrified
to have how do we build you up to where
you can have that how do we decrease
your anxiety and difficulty to have that
go have it and they go have it and it
reorients their whole brain and their
whole life starts to change and they
start fixing their life because then
they can have the next conversation and
the next one and the next one their
brain chemistry balances out they're
they're porn addictions go down even as
their brain chemistry balances out it's
incredible to watch but it is almost
always one conversation away from fixing
their life and that conversation makes
them feel like they're going to die if
they try to have it that's that's
everything
why is that the case why do we fear the
difficult conversations that we have to
have so much
as kids we learn this is attachment this
is what I teach as kids we learn that
somebody is not going to take our needs
seriously and in fact that if we try to
get them to take it seriously they're
going to hurt us they'll abandon us
they'll tell us we're not worthy of
their time they'll brush us off they'll
yell at us so trying to get someone to
take our feelings or our needs seriously
is terrifying and in fact when we're
little kids it can get you abandoned and
that abandonment is linked to death when
you're a little kid but you you feel
like you're going to die so it's an
amygdala response that forms the
theories go that amygdala's amygdala
memories stay with us for life you
remember that opening up and asking for
help gets you hurt really bad to an
extent that you can't take ever again
because it could destroy you so then one
big conversation is the most terrifying
thing on earth people would rather face
physical pain than that emotion or that
social pain
what is your advice to somebody who
probably knows that they do have an
incredibly uncomfortable conversation
they've been putting it off for
weeks months years and now they are
almost in a relationship with that
relationship they have with the
conversation
where do they go where are the first
steps that they go to to get past that
figure out what outcome you want for
that relationship with that person what
relationship would you rather have with
them than the one you have right now the
fake one that you have right now then
take that relationship pitch it to the
person and say I want this relationship
with you to get there we have to
overcome this issue here is how I would
like this conversation to go do you want
that conversation do you want that
relationship also if so how can we
together handle this issue here's what I
need what do you need and you build a
solution focused approach to solving
that problem that is cooperating during
conflict that is how you build a secure
attachment that's how you build great
relationships this is also how you
prevent the other person from exploding
in your face as long as they are a
halfway reasonable human being they
probably want the same vision of
relationship you do and if the you give
them hey this is what we're going to do
to get there they don't have to fight
you or defend against you it's not an
accusation it's let's solve this to get
to that and that makes it so much easier
if you can approach it that way you'll
solve most of your relationship woes
what is the other side of the fence here
so that is the pathway for somebody who
needs to have a conversation to have it
you mentioned people are likely to take
a pill for yours they don't understand
in opposition or instead of having a
difficult conversation
what happens when somebody continues to
Tamp down the things that they know that
they're supposed to say what's going on
in the brain in the body with everything
else
so those people end up usually really
deficient on oxytocin and oxytocin is
crucial for managing your physical pain
so a lot of these people end up with
chronic pain issues oxytocin also
releases Gaba gamma aminobiric acid Gaba
is responsible for a lot of melatonin
and helping you sleep at night and relax
your body it helps you use magnesium
effectively to manage stress it's an
inhibitory neurotransmitter for crushing
down anxiety depression symptoms and all
of those are missing if you don't have
those healthy relationships with good
conversations your high cortisol will
actually block that production of
oxytocin which will block the production
of that Gaba as well so have the
conversations your pain will start
diminish emotionally mentally physically
everything will start to diminish and
your satisfaction in life will go up you
have to have those conversations because
it's killing you not to
I suppose it's a a double-edged sword
that people who need to have
conversations will often lie awake at
night thinking about the conversation
that they haven't had but they've also
created this neurochemical Foundation
which is restricting their ability to
sleep as well that's right that's right
A lot of my clients will take a uh they
they will what is the word micro dose a
little bit they'll experiment with micro
dosing sometimes they just need to learn
physical body techniques to manage their
anxiety whatever it takes to decrease
the anxiety enough to go have the
conversation that's the point of
pharmaceuticals with with mental
Pharmaceuticals most of them is decrease
the symptoms to do the work so get the
symptoms down do the work and you
shouldn't need those Pharmaceuticals
much after that because you've already
solved the problem that was there in the
first place
most cases of depression are a natural
response to our broken Society we gain
much of our sense of worth purpose
meaning and Joy from our relationships
but those relationships have never been
more systematically destroyed than they
are today how have they been
systematically destroyed how do you
categorize modern society as being
broken
so we look back 200 years ago it wasn't
perfect but families we had we had five
safety nets that if a family didn't go
right a child would connect to one of
their five safety nets you've got your
core nuclear family you've got your
extended family Network around that
grandmother's grandfather's uncles aunts
cousins you've got the Kiff and kin
Network after this so you've got like
way out family members you've got the
surrounding family friends the friends
that you have are going to grow up with
you've got your neighborhood your tribe
your village your little town the people
around you outside of that that you can
connect to and then you've also got your
religious connections your religious
identity the religious Network and
Community you're tapped into those five
pieces if your family doesn't connect
with you somebody outside that family
will a grandmother and aunt somebody
will step in you've got your kith and
kin Network people to grow up with peers
and other people to connect with these
this is where you'd get married most
likely you've got your overall Village
your connection point with the other
people around you right maybe a thousand
people and then you've got your
religious connections as well um Jr
Tolkien he was raised by a priest his
that was his safety Network everything
else fell through he was still raised by
a priest and brought us Lord of the
Rings there are so many connection
points Within These five and all of
those are pretty much gone now except
you got your nuclear family which even
that is shattered especially here in
America those five networks are crucial
and if you don't have them kids slip
right through the net all the way down
to suicide
um what would you say to the people who
wouldn't predict or don't understand why
worth purpose meaning and joy come from
relationships a lot of people will find
this from their work from Pursuits that
they have uh from the kind of content
that they consume stuff like that to
think of relationship first
purpose-filled lives seems I don't know
it it doesn't seem very common
I hear that I understand that part of
that is because most people don't have
those relationships so they didn't grow
up experiencing what it's like to have
an impact on another human being to feel
a connection with another human being
they didn't grow up with much of that so
nobody impacted them in a much of a
positive way they can't understand then
and calibrate around trying to have an
impact on other people so an artist many
artists yes they're creating because
they have that desire to create but
their legacy Focus for their art is to
impact other people to drive them to
think to help people to grow to inspire
other artists an author is not just
writing a book for themselves an author
is writing a book for an audience for
human beings a therapist is not just
becoming a therapist because it will be
satisfying to them to be a therapist
they are going to make an impact on the
world your job your craft your hobby all
of these create human impacts and if
you've never experienced a human impact
yourself it's very difficult to imagine
what kind of human impact you could
create that would then be worthwhile
file to create a legacy you Chris man
watching you has been incredible but
think about your human impact of this
show you're not doing a podcast because
you enjoy talking into a microphone you
are changing the culture you are
uplifting certain voices right you are
changing the conversation the macro
conversation our micro conversation is
going to echo through that macro
conversation out in society and start
making a shift you are having a
tremendous human impact on the human
race and you are one person doing that
your work has tremendous meaning that
way because that human impact but if
nobody ever listened to your show ever
or was ever touched by your show
they wouldn't have that same meaning to
you
yeah that makes sense I I remember we
had a conversation one of the previous
episodes about uh pan generational
houses and the Rarity of that now so uh
I think you had this super viral tweet a
couple of years ago that said something
like a don't forget that moving out of
home is a psyot by the government to
make you have two mortgages instead of
one
um you know because and it was it's so
obvious in retrospect you think you know
families would have had three
generations four generations of not just
your straight nuclear family but
extended family too living on
some sort of farm working for a farmer
you know even if it's not your farm it's
you and your family are within that yep
I was seeing some research I think uh it
might have been you I see you so often
on Instagram I can't even I just
attribute everything to you now
um but there was some research that
shows that
by the time your child is 12 years old
you've already spent 75 percent of the
time in your life that you will spend
with them now in modern world by the
time they are 18 you've spent 90 percent
of the time you're likely to spend with
them across the course of your life you
only have about 10 percent left through
the course of their entire adulthood
that you are going to touch base with
them or see them and that is a very
modern concept because that is not how
humans are meant to function to go like
that and Scatter that hard 20
what are those numbers about a hundred
years ago most people didn't move more
than 15 miles from the place of their
birth they wouldn't even travel more
birth or they would get lost and never
be able to find their way home now what
do we do I'm just gonna pack up on a
move to Dubai then maybe I'll move to
Australia I saw my parents four or five
years ago I don't remember I don't know
what Dad's doing oh he's dead well
that's really sad I okay well I will cry
later but first I have to fly to France
this is becoming so much more common and
one of my dearest friends
um his his all of the children in his
family scattered and finally wonderfully
they all came back together to have
children to get married they gathered
around their mother who was 57 years old
and only only maybe five to ten years
away from retirement age and all of her
family was there all of her kids were
there her grandkids were there and then
she got a job offer for an extra ten
thousand dollars a year if she moved 12
hours away so completely she just did it
wasn't even a conversation in the family
it wasn't well what all the
opportunities we'll miss kids won't even
see Grandma no it was ten thousand
dollars that's great and they simply
packed up and moved 12 hours away after
this miracle reuniting of her entire
family that that is Modern Life
yeah that's terrifying you've got
another one here everyone talks about
how horrible the dating scene is for men
today but the picture is painted as if
women love the dating scene that's
because most men look at women and think
they're having a great time but most
women are miserable in dating as well
foreign
I'm thinking of the way that pornography
if a guy's been watching porn since he
was 8 10 12 years old here in America if
it's 10 12 is a lot where a lot of guys
are introduced to porn they think women
are just if a woman walks into a dark
alley and five men grab her and have sex
with her she's having the time of her
life this is great because a guy hey if
I walked into an alley and five women
start having sex with me that would be
wonderful I hope that happens like I
would pay money for that the things men
would pay money to experience women can
wander out and experience anytime they
want and guys look at that and say women
must love it they're lucky they are so
happy they get to date anyone they want
they can Bang everybody on the first
date she could bang 15 guys this week if
she wants to she must be having the time
of her life and then you look at women
and you talk to them and even the ones
who have tried hookup culture the vast
majority of them say it was awful I was
trying to find love I was sleeping with
them hoping they would love me I thought
it was supposed to be free and
liberating and it's terrible and I'm
miserable do some women fall into it and
say well this is supposed to be
fulfilling so I guess it's fine yeah but
those women many people often eat
McDonald's too and they'll say well the
chicken nuggets are really healthy at
McDonald's that's what I eat it's it's
if you are used to only having slop
available then you try to find the
healthiest slop you can and that's where
most women are in the dating pool right
now and guys think that women are just
on cloud nine and they are just
wonderful happy princesses who are so
joyous that ain't true not even close
not even close
you know I think
um trying to turn down the animosity
between men and women is is a pretty
important sort of counter push at the
moment you know this uh look at all of
the matches that women are getting on on
dating apps I'm like yeah but have you
ever asked a normal attraction
attractiveness woman to see the sorts of
messages that she gets from Men on
online dating apps it's [__]
catastrophic like it's absolutely I
don't know who these guys are because
they're certainly not the guys that I
know and they're certainly not the guys
that I'm showing it to they're like what
the [__] is this like what how why why
would somebody try and say this and
yeah it's
the lack of understanding from both
directions and I had this conversation a
few weeks ago that the challenges of men
and women in modern dating for women are
often problems of abundance and for men
are problems of scarcity and the
problems of scarcity can
seem more Noble in a way because you go
well look you know like at least you
have options I don't even have options
but when you fold in the sort of
physical vulnerability that women have
and the [__] shaming and concern of
derogating her value and I'm gonna go on
a date with this guy and you know me too
who's created this echo of kind of
ambient anxiety for all women whether
it's Justified or truthful or not
it creates an environment in which it's
really really uncomfortable for a lot of
women in the dating market and because
they seem to be like just swimming in D
guys presume oh well they're having a
great time I mean well I don't know I I
don't think that it's the case I think
that you would have a lot more happy men
if there were a lot more happy women
I agree I have I have so many people
coming to you let me ask you this Chris
conventional wisdom and and your own
experience
um I have a swarm of people coming into
my DMs and the coaching my group even
just talking to me on the internet and
they are
overwhelmingly Desiring a committed
monogamous relationship do you think
it's mostly women or mostly men that I
get
hmm
yeah women women but I can see it coming
from I could see it coming from both
sides
both you're right you got you nailed it
it is both there are so many men
desperate to find a committed monogamous
relationship with a woman who will just
be loyal and honest to them and just
kind loyal and kind those are the two
things I hear most of all that men are
looking for women same thing I want a
honest
stable man is what they are usually
looking for honest and stable or
honorable is another one that they also
say but here's what happens is I tell
them okay
are you on the first date being clear
that you are looking for a committed
relationship not asking for one but
being clear that's what you want at the
end of the first date you say just so
we're on the same page I'm looking for a
long-term committed relationship what
are you looking for do you do that oh I
can't do that they'd get up and run from
the table no one wants to hear that men
don't want that or women don't want that
you would think men are like women don't
want commitment they're just having fun
I've ever heard it is like dangling
commitment is how men get sex from women
that's how much women want it but men
today have got this Psy up against them
that women don't want commitment
you've got this tweet which relates look
most men in America are just wanting an
honest monogamous relationship with a
woman who's not going to betray them or
Rob them blind and right now most men
under 30 don't believe that sort of
relationship is possible no one wants to
acknowledge this disaster
that's right that's so right it's why
are there more Angry scared in cells why
are more guys running into red pill why
are guys committing suicide at
catastrophic numbers right now as we're
filming this there's guys committing
suicide that won't even hear this that
need to hear this
it's because they don't believe they
don't believe women want commitment they
don't believe women will ever be loyal
to them they've never experienced
kindness usually from other people I've
got other tweets on there that you've
seen I know you've seen of
um men that haven't had a hug or a
compliment in five to ten years they
haven't experienced human kindness they
know what that's like then they go out
into the dating pool hoping to just find
a woman that they can quietly live
alongside hoping she'll stay with him
like a magical creature that's just in
his presence it's horrible it's horrible
and men and women are both miserable but
men unfortunately do things about their
misery
70 of divorces are initiated by women
but it usually follows years and years
and years of them begging men to take
their relationships seriously guys will
get online and talk about being
blindsided after 20 years of marriage
but usually dismissed every possible
sign
I wrote this book right up here above my
head exhausted wives bewildered husbands
for this reason is women
as man as much as crap as women get on
the internet about no women are loyal
they're all faithless creatures man they
will stay you've probably seen women
stay with some guy for a long time who
isn't worthy of her and keep asking how
to fix their relationship do you get a
lot of women asking you like hey Chris
how can I fix my relationship do you get
a lot of that I get bombarded by those
questions
thankfully not they they don't come to
me for that kind of advice I mean my DM
requests are a bit of a cesspool but
um yeah there's all sorts of stuff in
there I definitely think that looking at
the cliche of the woman that stays I
mean women stay with men that beat them
yes women stay with women stay with men
that cheat on them women stay with men
that do all man they've got gambling
addictions they've yes fritted away the
entire family Nest Egg all this sort of
stuff like yeah it's
it's really interesting to think about
this like the this Insight that guys do
get blind side I don't know what
happened just one day she up and left
yeah well
I don't know man what happened for the
two decades before that correct correct
and that's usually what it is is he
really doesn't think that it was a big
problem most men they don't track
problems unless the woman is clear this
is a problem and here's how we're going
to fix it they have no understanding if
the man doesn't believe it's a problem
or doesn't believe there's an alternate
or a solution he's not going to solve
the problem the male brain looks
observes and fixes it and acts upon
looks and acts upon if he says she is
whining for no reason she wants constant
Euphoria there is no such thing as real
love I'm giving her everything I can
don't I give you my paycheck every time
every time I get one they they they map
their ability to love onto that and say
there's nothing more than this and they
don't take it seriously until she's
ready to leave then he freaks out but
she's already given up she's already
given up by the time he says wait I'm
willing to take it seriously now let's
go to therapy let's go to this let's go
to that then they go into into couples
to coaching or couples therapy and it's
he just says I'm done I'm tired I'm
miserable then he's done this for 20
years and the therapist rips him apart
and it's a hellish experience and that's
that's usually what that is she's
already given up man if men could you
mean learn to track those questions more
carefully it would work
what do you mean when you say take their
relationships seriously
take
the ability to give and receive love
seriously take her her feelings
seriously take his own desires seriously
learn what love is and what it's
supposed to be learn what emotional
intimacy is and do it believe he will be
taken seriously and open up to her right
you point out brilliantly earlier that
well the conversation online about
vulnerability is if you are ever
vulnerable to your wife she will
instantly leave the house and sleep on
with your best friend on your front lawn
as you are inside still touch with your
mouth open having shared something
personal with her and that's just not
true yes if you whine and SOB
uncontrollably on the floor for six
months about a problem with ever out
ever getting up and fixing it she may
lose respect for you and over time if
you just sit there yes she may not
respect you as a man anymore but women
crave vulnerability they crave emotional
intimacy it's how their sex drive Works
after the first 12 months it drops off a
cliff if you don't build that so build
the emotional intimacy she's not going
to cheat on you
related to what you just said there men
are often demonized in the first session
of couples therapy there are two big
reasons for this one women are usually
better at articulating their grievances
to criticize a woman too early and she
is likely to stomp out of the session
men will just take it so this is this is
really interesting because it's showing
us
um both what happens from the client
side and also from the practitioner side
as well that there's there's behind the
curtain and in front of the curtain are
kind of working together here
I I remember going through schooling so
it was six years for a master's degree
and then three years of focused
apprenticeship under other clinicians to
become a licensed marriage or family
therapist nine-year experience and I
remember the training they gave us about
be careful with female clients and
couples therapy because they have come
in expecting that their feelings will be
validated don't smother and stomp on the
guy because all of you guys will do that
the woman will be better at crying about
her feelings she will have a list of
grievances the guy is in there treating
you like the enemy already so validate
her feelings try not to stomp on him and
then a lot of therapists would just go
in there and do exactly that because
she's crying her eyes out he's he never
loved me never cares I do all these
things and he's like I'm sorry you know
I'm really sorry that you're having
these feelings and then therapists are
like well this is the direction you guys
want to go cool hey guy here's the
things you must do if you want to be a
decent and then it just turns into this
big Fest about let's fix the guy and
meanwhile the woman's challenges and the
things she's contributing go completely
under the rug and the guys are exhausted
by this there's a point there's a reason
they don't want to go to couples therapy
anymore
what about women are usually better at
articulating their grievances
very very common for that I this
happened it made me feel this way I
didn't like it here's what I need you to
do instead most guys can't articulate
their emotions that way most guys have
no idea what what did I feel I don't
know why would I talk about my feelings
uh this made me mad don't ever do it
again and then it sounds like he's just
yelling at them and ordering them around
it sounds awful women will typically use
more of what's called non-violent
communication it makes them sound better
it makes them look better women have
better PR while they are talking about
their feelings and therapists will say
wow you're using good therapy language
because women have read so many books
they've done therapy themselves they've
watched therapy dramas they have they
know how to use the language that has
seeped into our culture men often don't
so it is you walk in and a lot of times
the woman instantly forms a connection
with the therapist the guy is blindsided
and it's just a it's a horrible
experience for the men most of the time
yeah I suppose this isn't to kind of lay
therapy Behavior at the feet of
manipulative women it's just that they
they have an unfair Advantage when it
comes to communicating and articulating
the problems that they've got they've
probably spoken to their girl friends
about this issue they've had a dry run
of this 200 times before already and
also I think based on one of our
previous conversations you said that
it's almost always the woman that gets
the couple to go into counseling in any
case
yeah almost always unless it's his Hail
Mary pass at the very end because she
has been absolutely done with the
relationship and he pitches it as a
last-ditch effort and then he's going to
walk in and be endlessly apologetic
anyway and she's going to share all her
grievances even more and it's going to
get even worse so I remember as a
marriage family therapist I had to work
through that and they'd come in and I
have to make sure I did not take a side
that I did not Stomp all over him that I
had invalid it over validate her but I
remember I'd say what brings you guys in
here and she would some of the women
would clear their throat and they would
open their purse and she would pull out
a written list a written list
and the guy's eyes would like widen and
he would just I could see him like brace
for impact and it it it's amazing it is
amazing what happens inside the therapy
room sometimes and if the therapist
isn't guarded if they're not aware if
they haven't received adequate training
if they haven't taken care of their own
problems if they're you know if they're
all overly indulging of of women anyway
in those circumstances right think of
police right two people two people
punching each other the police pull up
they arrest the man and they throw him
in handcuffs uh one of my one of my very
dear friends was in an awful abusive
relationship and the woman was punching
him over and over and over in the face
and he was trying to get away and she
pursued him continuing to punch him so
he grabbed her wrists to stop her from
punching him in the face because he was
so bruised and the police pulled up and
his face was covered in bruises and he
said she's punching me and they said
you're holding her wrist so they put him
in handcuffs tossed him on the curb held
him down and then talked to her to see
if she wanted to hold press charges as
his face is all bruised from her
punching him and she even admitted yeah
I punched him and he grabbed my wrist
okay well he could go to jail do you
want us to take him right now that's
that's you got to remember that that is
brought into therapy too and you got to
control for that
how much are couples using therapists
as like a mediator or as almost a
communication tool rather than as an
expert that can help them work through
things it seems to me based on a lot of
the stories I've heard from you that
it's just an opportunity to vent you
know they they're shouting things into
The Ether but they don't actually need
to turn and face the partner that's sat
next to them because they can tell it to
this
independent third party and just blast
it but really they're not saying it for
the therapist they're finally getting
the opportunity to take the uh
stabilizers off and and unleash all of
this pentapango
you know what that is almost the better
option of what can happen and what they
trained us for in therapy and they
warned us in school was this the vast
majority of people of couples that come
in have one of two outlooks one you are
going to prove I'm right and change my
partner for me or two I have already
given up and I just need to prove it's
not going to work by having a
professional tell us it's not going to
work those are the two biggest mindsets
that come into fit into couples therapy
and they said you will oversee so many
breakups and so many divorces that you
will want to quit your job so you need
to brace yourself for the burnout that
is coming as a couple's therapist
because it is just a meat grinder they
said you might be able to save
five to ten percent of couples who come
into couples therapy because only five
to ten percent actually want a better
relationship
daycare has been shown to harm the
ability to bond and feel secure
especially for babies their mental
health outcomes later in life are
impacted research proves this saying
this out loud can get you fired
oh man we've already people are already
mad
um just from hearing that but yeah I I
post this online and I get a flood of
DMS from people demanding answers
telling me I'm a liar and all I do is
pull up one of the longest running
studies in human history about daycare
conducted by the Canadian government and
just send them the link that shows how
daycare especially early in life and
especially in large amounts outcomes 10
20 years later in that child's life much
worse more anxiety more symptoms more
addictions more broken relationships and
broken marriages more problems in their
life
strongly correlated with that daycare
piece now does it definitively prove it
was just the daycare no was it massively
correlated in gigantic amounts that is
concerning absolutely so yes that amount
of daycare right there very very
difficult what they've shown is that
even putting your kids with Grandma or
an aunt or a relative is even better
than putting them into daycare with
strangers that's what the Research
indicates
what are the age range risks primarily
for this presumably putting them into
daycare once they're four years old like
you know they're basically in school
then and I don't think that many people
would look at school as being something
that would negatively impact Health
outcomes later in life because kids are
going to be at least a little bit more
well adapted by then well American
public schools might negatively impact
their life outcome what the research
shows is that if you put a kid in public
school there's a 9.3 chance that they're
going to be sexually harassed or
sexually abused by a staff member it's
almost 10 percent here in America so
it's one in ten just keep that in mind
for public school here in America it's
brutal uh however yeah you're right it
is the lower rates the the lower ages
they're born and Mom puts them in
daycare within two weeks here in the
United States maternity leave is does
that happen even if you can oh yeah it's
daycare after two weeks that's a couple
weeks yeah daycare it put maternity here
in America is a joke it is a joke if you
can get the time off cool if you have
have money saved up to be able to pay
for it cool if your company has good you
know maternity coverage good things like
that great a lot of moms can't so a lot
of moms they end up two three weeks
maybe they can get six weeks maybe
that's really like oh you got six weeks
off wow good for you here in America so
imagine putting your little baby at six
weeks into daycare and you're not going
to see them for 12 hours so in the
morning you're exhausted getting up you
don't see them for 12 hours dump them
off with strangers who hopefully take
care of them but they're not Mom and
you're not probably having oxytocin
bonding experiences as a baby like they
would if they were on you all the time
even just skin contact and end of the
day you are exhausted so beginning of
this we talk about those mirroring
things you don't mirror much to them you
don't engage them and talk with them and
do endless mirroring with them they've
just kind of sat there all day watching
other people and they know when he
engages with them and they're afraid
because they're alone among strangers
this is why daycare is so brutal for
young kids yeah four five six if you're
doing daycare for six hours a day you
know something like that maybe a little
bit better
um but especially those early ages when
you're forming the brain when you're
teaching about love teaching about
bonding teaching about connection
absolutely not man
yeah I I didn't know that's the first
time hearing about the way that American
maternity leave works in the UK mothers
get nine months batches together so they
can my business partner's wife has
worked I think up until pretty much he
was ready to pop each time because she
wanted to maximize the amount of time oh
yeah available after that but yeah nine
months and then uh she did something
else I feel like she had I'm pretty sure
because she had three kids
I I feel like she did something I'm
pretty sure she managed to get sort of
30 months off over the space of like
four or four and a bit years so you know
this very very large chunk of time for
all of these different kids and then
when you've had multiple kids you you're
overlapping kids upon kids right so yeah
it was um that's wild to hear that the
US has so he said no mandatory or
mandated maternity leave at all well
there there are there are
um the pay is often not great and
especially if your employer has to pay
then you get three four women on staff
who will go on maternity at the same
time they can pressure you to come back
um there's there's all kinds of problems
that really contribute to this but
there's not much protection for it
there's almost no paternity leave
anywhere all four of my children when
they were born I had to just take unpaid
vacation unpaid time off or use my
vacation time or sick time I got one
week off with each of my children a
single week and when the first one was
born we were so poor I could barely even
afford one week it was a giant financial
hardship for us to be able to take one
week no pay it was rough so yeah fathers
no almost zero paternity leave and
mothers massive massive pressure to go
back to work as soon as possible
especially the financial pieces it's
there's almost there's very little time
that moms can really take off here in
America at all we just dump them
straight into daycare and then daycare
is so massively expensive that if you
have two kids you may as well quit your
job because you're just paying for
daycare at that point so yeah of course
but you're just cycling through it if
the money comes from me from the
employer to me directly to the daycare
and then there's this conduit I'm just
this conduit in the middle all right
next one yes most men don't know how
female communication Works they provide
Solutions which is what they would want
when a woman wants validation when this
is pointed out most men assume it's
untrue because they'd hate to receive
only validation instead of a solution
so true is this surprising to you I want
to ask you because you're about one of
the most conversations
after all the conversations that we've
had um this this one seems pretty
aligned with everything that you've
taught me but the validation solution
framework I I didn't know how much of it
is a cliche how much of it is just
stereotype you know that you know even
in sitcoms and stuff women will say like
I don't want you to give me a solution I
just want you to hear me rant and I
didn't know if that was real but
accordingly think about this way I think
it is let's make this make sense so when
a woman has a difficult experience
during her day and she comes home and
she puts down her purse and the husband
says hi sweetheart how was your day and
she draws a deep breath and she's going
to tell him everything that has happened
today and about how her work enemy did
this and how she ate this for lunch and
her shoe didn't look quite right and she
will unload all of these things here's
what's happening a couple things are
happening number one her logical brain
is diminished to fuel an emotional Spike
over on the emotional agitation side of
the brain that's one thing that's
happening so when you are stressed out
that's what happens your logic is
diminished your emotions go high but you
want to do what women do is they process
this with other women and as the other
woman says wow oh I'm so sorry whoa wow
oh that's amazing oh and they give him a
hug and they just talk it through the
agitation decreases so those mirroring
neurons come back in she's not upset
she's not scared it's not a big deal I
don't have to stress about this and she
cares about me she's listening to me I'm
worthy of her time and then she gave me
a hug it releases all kinds of oxytocin
again Gaba releases after that it
inhibits the anxiety response oh I feel
so much better I am loved I am cared for
someone gave me their time and I don't
have to feel upset I feel so much better
after 20 minutes of endless talking
right women get this with each other
they do this men the woman comes home
well this happened and this happened he
goes wait I already have a solution for
you because the male brain observes a
problem and then acts upon it I found
the solution that we instantly like you
should do this and she goes and she
stops because her logical brain is
diminished she's not ready for a
solution yet she's trying to decrease
agitation and bond at the same time
she's saying I'm giving you everything
of myself you're going to know about me
we're going to bond we're going to share
nope here's a solution what he has just
done is said take this get out of my
face I don't have time for you go over
there please I'm going to go do this
thing he's accidentally doing that he
he's loving it he's like hey I gave you
a solution we found it that fast we
didn't even have to talk for 20 minutes
we talked for three seconds this is
great complete disconnect she's feels
shut down he thinks he's done great her
demeanor cools down she gets very
standoffish and goes uh oh what's that
what's wrong babe nothing nothing is
wrong and she shuts down and they do
this over and over and over that's how
it breaks down so guys number one thing
please for the love of God if she starts
talking
hey babe I really want to hear the story
do you want me to just share and or are
you wanting me to find a solution I just
want to make sure I give you what you're
looking for right here okay you want me
to listen awesome I am here for it and
you settle in with a bag of popcorn you
just eat and you just wow that's amazing
like it's the best movie ever that the
problem is not whatever the problems you
think they are the problem is she wants
to bond with you solve that problem by
giving her what she wants if you do this
you will be the greatest husband on the
face of the Earth
what is the reverse what is it that
women don't know about how male
communication works and what do they get
wrong
men bond by teaching we bond by teaching
and sharing Solutions mansplaining a
large portion of mansplaining is men
saying I care enough about you to give
you this information man look at this
podcast you asked me a question and I
start teaching and I start guide like
this is how men do and if we hit
something where you're like yeah I know
that part we skip it through it men will
say I know that part skip ahead I know
that part skip ahead and we do that
until we catch up women don't do this
women will just sit and listen to you
and think why is he telling me the most
basic stupid things on the face of the
Earth why is he teaching me as if I'm a
child he thinks I'm a child because they
would only talk to a child that way so
they he thinks I'm a child he's treating
me this is such disrespect and the man
is saying they're going man this is
great I'm teaching her she's listening
this is wonderful and he thinks he's
bonding and then later he gets a call
from HR about mansplaining this is one
of the biggest things right here if a
man teaches and shares and explains he
is deeming you worthy of passing on
knowledge and expertise if he's being a
dick about it yeah that's another
problem but most men just want to teach
you they bond with you they release
vasopressin and oxytocin while they're
doing this and they expect you're doing
the same one of the best things a woman
can do is ask a man to teach her or
train her in something it will bond him
to you so much better than sex
men get retroactively jealous of a
woman's sexual past because they think
about how much hypothetical fun they
would have had if they did what she did
but most women would trade their whole
past for one loving partner for life
it's a huge difference in perspectives
so let's sort out two things here
because I post this and I get all kinds
of guys angry like Adam don't you
realize there's a biological reason men
would like a woman who's had low number
of Partners well yes I do I recognize
that 100 100 I married a woman myself
who was had had no Partners previously
um so I totally understand that there's
a good biological reason for a man to
want a woman who does not have 300
Partners totally fine totally understand
that retroactive jealousy though is I
think she did X Y and Z so she's gonna
go do it with someone else again I'm
holding her back or I'm not going to be
good enough or there's a massive
pressure on the guy especially if she's
has experiences he hasn't had massive
Expressions on the and and pressure on
the guy to try to perform perform he
sees again women in porn and well she
wants this they are always happy in porn
when they do this no no no no no no so
most women will tell you that they got
involved in in Wild sexual experiences
to try to get someone's approval to try
to be interesting to try to have some
stimulation because they were so
depressed or so unhappy I have never
never met a woman that said I love my
sexual past because it was so fun and
fulfilling the only women who might say
that are excessively avoidant women who
have no idea what emotional intimacy
feels like so they they rely only on
stimulation and these are a tiny
minority of the population most women
will say I'm glad about my sexual past
only because it led me to the man I am
with now and now I am so fulfilled in
our sex life because it is so intimate
and bonded that's what they usually
focus on women aren't really focused on
have the biggest as many as many penises
and as many large ones as possible and
and 50 000 men and okay now I'm ready to
settle down that's not really how it
goes like men think that's how men think
right sowing your Wild Oats that's a man
thing women usually are looking for that
connection and they have no idea how to
get it and they are so happy when
they're in a good relationship with you
what would your advice be to a guy that
is struggling to deal with his female
partner's sexual past
number one be realistic if you can
handle it right if you if she's your
first ever partner and she's had a
hundred people and you're like this is
all if it's overwhelming you might need
to just call it because it might be too
much it just might you might not be able
to handle it to be honest with you no
judgment on you either way Society may
call you all kinds of things but no I
get it like it may not be it may not be
right number two if there's a religious
component to it and if she's like no it
was great that I did that and you're
really she's really avoidant then maybe
it's not going to be for you but what
you need to do is this sit down and talk
to her about her sexual uh desires now
her feelings now her beliefs about sex
now how seriously does she take it how
seriously does she take the bond that
happens what does she actually want from
you how fulfilled was she in those
experiences emotionally fulfilled talk
to her about that hey you did X Y and Z
what was that like for you that's the
question most men don't have the guts to
ask hey you had a threesome with two
dudes what was what was that mentally
and emotionally like for you was it a
great time guys imagine the opposite and
we think it's going to be amazing was it
amazing most women will say no it was
really disappointing but what about the
terror if you're the the love of your
life looks into your eyes and says yeah
it was really really fun when I had two
dudes in one bed that's it could be like
cause some guy's heart to fall out it it
could be then you need to know that
don't shy away from the truth bro ask
the truth get the truth and then say
okay is that something that I'm holding
you back from experiencing in our
relationship do you want to go have that
experience again
she's probably if she's with you most
likely to say no I do not want those
experiences again I actually value our
connections so much more than any of the
fun I've ever had that's it I'm not
saying women have never had fun I am
saying that emotional intimacy is the
massive driver for the real real bonding
orgasm the female orgasm it's driven by
oxytocin oxytocin builds through the
emotional connection you share and then
it builds more through foreplay as long
as you do it you don't do it foreplay
for an hour it will tank but you do the
emotional bonding all day long through
the relationship and then the foreplay
and then sex and this is how women often
can orgasm through vaginal stimulation
without clitoral stimulation they can do
this when their oxytocin is very high
typically the research is cool on this
and then they can have multiple orgasms
because it keeps chaining their org
their oxytocin higher and higher and
higher a lot of women who can't orgasm
I've worked extensively with couples
where the woman cannot orgasm building
the relationship and the emotional
intimacy builds incredible orgasm
experiences for them oxytocin that
emotional intimacy is the bonding Point
for women it is female Viagra so if guys
out there if you're jealous of her past
talk about the the Fulfillment she
experienced and what would be more
fulfilling now talk about that because
you're going to find you are the one who
fulfills her more than any of those
people ever could have
most men would rather hear their
Partners say they respect him than they
hear that they love him because respect
has an acknowledgment of power he holds
and The Honorable way he wields it
let me ask you Chris would you rather
hear I love you or I respect you
it's pretty close uh I don't actually
know I don't actually know uh
this like I've got a soft side to me so
hearing that someone loves me is really
nice but sure respect respect definitely
adds something that love doesn't and I
think that love adds something that
respect doesn't
um but I would I would guess that the
reverse is not true that if you to ask a
woman do you want to be respected by
your partner or loved by your partner
that they're not going to have this same
balancing act that I've got to try and
do not not usually they will say usually
that respect is part of love and that
love is the one that's that indicates
that respect is there but not so in the
reverse a woman can love a man but not
respect him and that's called the friend
zone and you will be friendzoned if you
do that that is the friend zone I love
you but I just don't see you as a guy
that that's the friend zone lack of
respect lack of sex drive lack of Desire
lack of trust so respect for men
ultimately more important Chris I mean
you are a respectable guy I respect you
but have you ever had a woman actually
think to say I respect you you have you
ever had that most women don't even
imagine that it's it's important
yeah it's it's not something that I hear
many of my friends saying that that
they've heard from their partners
I guess again the sort of theory of
cross-sex mind reading thing the failure
is
well as a woman why would I be but I'm
not bothered but like I want I want to
be respected but like the fact that
someone respects me is
I guess mandatory on Route toward being
loved but it's not something that I
actually strive to have and I think you
know a big a big chunk of this is
probably explained by the fact that
status is such a big determinant of a
man's
um survivability uh his reproductive
success it is going to be very difficult
for you to accumulate respect without
also having status alongside it so what
he hears when somebody says I respect
you is you are somebody worthy of high
status also and downstream from status a
whole host of benefits well honor right
a woman if a woman says I feel safe with
you that is very close to I respect you
I feel safe with you you are an
honorable man you are a good man they
usually stop shy of saying I respect you
very few women will actually think to
say I respect you to their men but if
women out there listening to this I'm
sure there's like a million women out
there right now learn to say I respect
you walk up to him put your hands on his
chest lean in and say I respect you like
watch his heart melt at that point
because it is there's trust there is
honor there is integrity there is
everything good wrapped up in that love
is I feel warmly towards you for most
men I feel warmly and affectionate
towards you and I will do what is best
for you cool that's love
you are an honorable respectable man
with integrity and I trust you
completely that's respect so guys out
there
push for respect More Than Love
many people reading the above tweets
about men needing to feel powerful will
view that as a negative the ability to
feed your children and keep a roof over
their head no matter what the economy is
doing that's power the ability to
achieve a mission that's power many
people today are terrified of the idea
of men having power because their only
frame of reference is abuse even men
feel this way which is why they shy away
from building the sort of power that
would save their life become an abuser
or commit suicide are their only choices
male power is terrifying in the modern
world but men must have power they want
to kill themselves
I'm a father I've got four kids I got
number five coming in the way I think
when you and I started I had like two
kids they're just popping out everywhere
I don't even know how it's happening
um I think my wife is just finding him
on the road I don't even know so I've
got five kids now coming out and
man groceries are expensive the US
economy is getting so much worse our
local grocery store had to put cameras
in the meat area not because people are
smuggling it out under the coats but
because families are swapping labels
from expensive meat to cheap meat so
that they or big packs of meat to small
packs of meat so that they can buy the
bigger packs of meat for the same prices
and not just Hooligans they are stealing
meat not for resale to feed their kids
families are stealing meat just to feed
their kids there's a lot of families
that have to choose what day of the week
they're going to feed their kids meat
right now in parts of this country and
it's it's worse overseas there's
families that you can't even have food
overseas right what day of the week are
we going to eat
fatherhood is about providing it's about
protecting it's about caring and and
doing that that's why respect is so
crucial because it's the ability to do
those things power is mandatory for men
and not the power to hurt people the
power to protect and the power to build
and create the positive aspect aspects
of masculinity like I always tell people
there's no there's no toxic masculinity
there is masculinity or the lack of
masculinity you Embrace responsibility
or you don't and to have responsibility
you have to have the power to fulfill it
yeah the um this sort of conversation
around toxic masculinity and where it
comes from I had a really interesting
framing of it where toxic masculinity
isn't too much masculinity but a lack of
it and you know more virtuous Integrity
driven honorable uh
respectable all of this folded together
into a conception of masculinity really
that to me seems to be the counter to
what is missing like to any most of the
modern conceptions put forward by the
mainstream media around what an
acceptable version of masculinity is
supposed to be sounds an awful lot like
stereotypical femininity
it is we want you to be feminine so we
feel safe that's usually what it is this
would make us feel safe no it won't
no it won't because then who's going to
protect you who's going to make you feel
safe in the world they are scared of men
they are terrified of men women are
petrified of men and right now men are
petrified of women we are all so
terrified of each other that men can't
be masculine because they're they'll
scare people and women have to be
masculine to try to protect themselves
from the perceived threats it's a
horrible world right now we need more
they're talking about uh many people
today are terrified of the idea of men
having power because the only frame of
reference is abuse and it's a tyranny as
well right it's that sort of tyrannical
overbearing
uncaring leader that hasn't got Prestige
but has managed to sort of in a
Machiavellian way get themselves into a
position where they can manipulate other
people and
I
I I understand I understand that
compulsion I understand that fear but
the alternative is like like this recent
lizzo Scandal around where it turns out
she wasn't body positive at all she was
it made body shaming the dancers and you
know that to me is the like female body
positivity equivalent of the sneaky
[__] syndrome for men that you have
this person who like ostensibly is out
there I'm such a I care about X and Y
and Z and then you find out secretly
that they're one of the worst
perpetrators of this I think Ellen
DeGeneres was the same it's the it's the
senator who is you know proclaiming
anti-gay bills all day before he goes
home to watch like gay porn on a VPN
from a non-work laptop
um it's just what is being pushed out
and what is being
um like pushed back against often
identify I think where people's desires
actually genuinely lie if you think
about this also is radical feminism
women who have feminist leanings will
close their circles except to people who
have feminist ideals which is I I loved
how you pointed that the sneaky [__]
syndrome you have men who engage deeply
in radical feminism to try to sneak in
and then they are the worst abusers so
then these women say Eve the The Men Who
get it are still horrible so how much
worse must all the other men out there
be and that really radicalizes them very
interesting because I saw there was do
you remember 10 years 10 15 years ago
there was a UK feminist who came out and
said all men are horrible we have to put
them in concentration camps women can go
visit them but the world will never be
safe until men are in camps I was like
where would someone get this idea well
if she's only been around male feminists
I'm thinking of was it the Weinstein
Scandal all of Hollywood all the male
feminists in Hollywood it turns on the
raping girls and raping people and and
all kinds of stuff that's why the the
best versions of men they have seen
turned out to be sneaky [__] abusers
and this is where we're coming from now
they are so scared because they think
that's the best version of man
have you seen this trend online of
liberal women lamenting the fact that
they can't find a man they're attracted
to who isn't conservative
yes absolutely
I think if it's horrible good chunk of I
think a good chunk of this is is played
into with that uh there's a streamer
dude
um who he's going viral on the internet
at the moment for basically saying that
if you are a liberal woman who cares
about her politics but decides to sleep
with a conservative guy uh you're basic
basically like you need to give you a
head of wobble what on Earth are you
doing this is kind of a betrayal of so
and so and so on and it's like just the
biggest display of intersexual
competition and feet stomping and toys
going out of the pram that I can imagine
it's like any guy that isn't me that
gets sex is unfair that's what I heard
that's also true that it guys will do
anything for sex if they are really
insecure they will do anything for sex I
mean we will build cultures to have sex
it is incredible what men will do to
have sex and the worse their insecurity
is the more they're willing to give up
or pretend or fake so I'm curious how
many of those women who go out and sleep
with conservative men the men were at
least upfront and honest and just
straightforward enough to say hey I'm
conservative these are my values and the
women probably responded to his honesty
his confidence and his Clarity of what
he believes and why it may not be he's
conservative that turns me on it might
be he is honest he is straightforward
and he's not afraid to tell me how he
feels and what he thinks because a lot
of guys will use liberal policies to say
I'm not like other guys I totally
understand please approve of me give me
a pat on the head give me a sympathy
screw that's a lot of what those women
see you've seen this data showing the
skew uh liberal versus conservative
amongst U.S school children at the
moment oh gosh it's really really Stark
it's it's just it's incredible females
um are really diverging liberal and
males are really diverging toward
conservative so yeah you're going to end
up with a scenario in which it's the
technical term for it is woke fishing
um you're going to have more and more
guys
portraying their liberal Bona fides or
pretending to have liberal Bonafide he's
putting those out front and saying you
know I yeah of course I care about the
environment and stuff and Nancy Pelosi I
don't actually really think that her
trades there's anything wrong with those
and you know all the way down
um because men will do a lot of things
to get laid include including pretending
to be a liberal but this is the this is
the thing that I wonder how much of this
is skewed I I know bags and bags of
liberal guys especially ones that live
here in Austin and they easily able to
be just as like upstanding as the
conservative guys what I think you're
maybe seeing is a skew here partly
because there is a lot of sneaky [__]
syndrome going on and people that don't
have these views but another part of it
is I wonder how many conservative dudes
have woke fished their way in and women
are like dude I I had this like one
night stand with this guy and he didn't
really seem all that truthful but he
said he was a liberal and he's like no
he wasn't he was a conservative in
Disguise so yeah I wonder I wonder how
much of that is is happening as well
look I grew up in California as a kid
and not too far from San Francisco there
was a lot as far I've never heard the
term woke fishing before but I have seen
it my entire life about guys will do and
say anything to have sex and then women
have no idea what happened afterward and
they're like what what where did you go
oh he's over there sleeping with other
women he told me he was gay and I was
turning him straight like I've seen that
stuff before like dudes will do anything
and so will women sometimes to have a
connection with the guy so that is not
shocking to me I will say this I've I've
worked with so many couples where they
come in very liberal and they get
married or or they're thinking about a
deeply committed relationship and they
will shame-facedly especially the women
tell me they find themselves falling
into gender right traditional gender
roles and they will ask me if that's
okay
I'm like does it work for you well yeah
but it's supposed to be bad and I feel
like I'm betraying feminism well is he
beating you with a stick every day and
you're wearing you know and you're
barefoot and pregnant in the kitchen and
like no well okay are you guys talking
about how it works for you yeah well why
do you think those traditional roles
have formed in most societies on Earth
because they're pretty effective for the
way our brains work do you feel trapped
in those roles no he's very considerate
when I talk about it okay yeah I say
explore it see how it works for you and
uh embrace it don't feel bad
okay I'll give it a try and then they're
so happy so happy after that they just
relax into it so I hope that in the
future that uh that may happen with the
the young men and young women right now
who are waiting to pair bond in the
wings who are who are growing into their
own maybe they will find some methods
that work for them regardless of liberal
or conservative I hope that they will
if you're a single parent and refuse to
allow your kids to see the other parent
just because that parent hurt your
feelings you don't actually love your
kids
love is an action it is doing what is
actually right for the other person
regardless of what it costs you if you
strip away a parent from your child an
Irreplaceable Bond because of your
feelings not for what the parent does to
the other because of the child but
because your feelings are hurt
you don't love your child you love
yourself and your own feelings
Point Blank
it's territorial and juvenile and
immature and short-sighted
and embarrassing
and possessive of a child they are an
object in your life designed to give you
feelings they are not somebody that you
are respecting the Dignity of and it's
leverage as well
it is over your right and it will teach
it will teach your children to do the
same back to you someday
yeah that you are
you are a chip to be Bartered with
um I had this conversation last week
talking about
parents who
struggle to get on board with
productivity strategies or they they
take offense at people talking about
productivity strategies like morning
routines and say stuff like um
tell me that you don't have kids without
telling me that you don't have kids
um because you talk about some
not even that elaborate but slightly
elaborate 30 minute morning routine that
you go through and what they're saying
is I I have kids therefore I can't do
this and Alex the dude I was speaking to
was like well I hope that their kids
never read that because if their kids
read it what do they read they read wow
mum and dad did you not get to fulfill
your dreams because you had me was do
you hate me was I not did I not make
your life better are you bitter about
the fact that you didn't get to do your
morning routine and instead we had to
play in bed together
those attitudes come through and your
interactions when they fight with you
when they push back on you you don't
respond you don't go online and complain
about your kids and how your kids are
holding you back from a good life and
then be completely loving and
compassionate and cooperative and build
a great life with your kids that's just
not how that split goes your attitude in
one place reflects your attitude during
stress and when you're gonna engage with
them look I got four kids man there are
there are times that are stressful when
you have many kids and even if one kid
and they throw tantrums and they pee on
the floor and they throw blocks at your
face and they say no I won't eat that no
I don't want to go to bed and they will
go to bed and then they will sneak out
of bed four times in a row you could
tell that this has happened
um
if you despise what you feel they have
taken from you if you despise the
sacrifices that that you need to make
and if you let those sacrifices be
everything in your life
then you will not handle them well
during those times of stress because you
will unload on them and unload your
frustrations on them during those times
instead
make sure that you are sacrificing the
right things in the right ways and
prioritizing my kids know I've I'm
looking over there in uh in my office
I've got a weight set over there my kids
know hey I'm a daddy's gonna step away
I'm gonna lift some weights daddy's
gonna go do this I just hired a personal
trainer I'm getting my Fitness on on
track I got to do that
um I gotta step away and take some
meetings for personal trainers daddy you
want why stay and play with me babe I
have to get my health on track so Daddy
can be with you for many many years to
come and I explained that context to
them build that and build that into your
family so your kids will do it too
that's what you do nice guy issues come
from anxious attachment style he grew up
afraid of his mother abandoning him so
all he knows is how to earn goodbye
points and approval to avoid abandonment
that's never going to make any woman
happy this is why nice guys finish last
and you really liked that other tweet I
did with the uh the werewolf and the
happy puppy nice guys look really fluffy
at first and then really vicious at the
end of it when you reject them it's
because they earn good boy points and
they are supposed to be rewarded they do
nice things for you expecting to be
repaid and you have to figure out what
they want it's usually sex you have to
figure out what they want and do it for
them or they will be furiously angry
that you didn't reciprocate the way the
rules say that you have to this is why
nice guys finish last is because they
just can't ask and they will come off as
a jerk eventually
you've seen this before I'm sure you
have absolutely I mean there's a really
great article by Vincent harinam about
um the the social economics of simping
and what he's talking about is that a
man who is too pliable
is kind of the same as a woman who gives
up sex too easily but the thing you know
if you presume that the the highest
value thing that a woman can offer a man
like Beyond commitment and love and like
all of the actual like [__] important
stuff but like as a front face resources
and Chastity right it's the trade
largely that that is part of one of the
main trades that gets made and a woman
who gives up Chastity without commitment
is people are skeptical of her and a man
who gives up resources without sex in
return people are also skeptical of him
it's why I think there is an awful lot
of social stigma around men who
subscribe to only fans men who give
gifts on Amazon gifts lists and stuff
like that because what those men are
doing is they're offering up something
which was supposed to be gate Captain
walled off for all men to like stand
firm we are all one unit and if the
women don't give us sex then they don't
get our resources and what you have now
is a man who is prepared to give up
resources without sex in the same way as
a woman who's prepared to give up sex
without commitment gets criticized by a
lot of women women who give up sex
without commitment drive down the market
price or the market value of sex to a
level where all other women need to meet
it if you are prepared to give up a
[__] on the first date and I want to
wait until the third date I now need
there's a price differential I now need
to uh degrade my own uh price my own the
value that I see my [__] at down to
that first date and the same thing
occurs with men if in order for a man to
give up his resources and be able to
financially support a woman the woman
needs to jump through a bunch of Hoops
that keeps the value of resources High
whereas and this is another one of the
reasons I think that there is a
particular amount of distaste from both
men and women towards only fans uh
creators that they see them as getting a
free ride and they see them as
capitalizing off the back of men who are
overly pliable men aren't happy with
either the men or the women because they
look at the women and think well I'm
never going to be able to get her
because what can I offer her that 10 000
men all combined how can I come compete
with ten thousand men's worth of
resources and the women aren't aren't
happy with her either because it seems
like she's like she does a lot of intra
sexual competition going on there so
yeah the the um resources thing the
overplayability of of men and it's
fundamentally why simping doesn't work
like you may
let's take that even one step further is
you know we're hunter-gatherers more
than anything our brains haven't even
caught up to the Neolithic Revolution
and the ideas of surplus and anything so
safety protection out in the world
um let's take that let's take it one
step further you're all your audience
they love historical examples so let's
talk about Vikings right the Danes a
thousand years ago raiding up and down
the coasts all over you the Britain all
over the UK
um the Danes if they sailed in you don't
want to be married to the guy that when
the Danes roll in they're like we demand
women and he's like well okay here's my
wife here's my daughter all right guys
sorry like you have to go live with the
Danes now you don't want that guy you
want the guy who plants his flag and
says this will never happen I'm going to
die first me and all the other guys are
going down to the beach to die for you
guys so that hopefully we will drive the
cost so high that they will leave if I
don't see you again I love you bye-bye
and he goes to die to protect his family
that's simps are gonna be like oh man
like well I'm really sorry I'm thinking
of um also another historical example
um there was a gentleman
during the Holocaust that he sent his
own wife and kids on the train knowing
knowing what was going to happen to them
he was sending people on the train he
put his own wife and kids on the train
when it was their turn didn't say
anything just loaded them on the wife on
the train and ship them away and after
the war when they had the tribunals when
they did everything they grab they found
him they found him much later on in life
and they brought him in and they put him
up on trial and he said there is nothing
you can do to me than is that is worse
than me living with the memory of what I
did to my wife and to my children
but he that was that right there was a
moment of why you don't marry a simp
that is why women don't respect simps
that's why they don't respect nice guys
it's the more agreeable you are it's not
just the agreeableness even it's the
weaker you are for approval for safety
you prioritize your own safety over
actually taking a stand for your morals
that's why Viking raids the Holocaust
even all the way back to just raiding
tribes in in hunter-gatherer times it's
safety that's what women understand
that's why they need to respect a man
before they'll really sleep with a man
long term
Adam Lane Smith ladies and gentlemen
Adam I love these episodes I always love
bringing you back on why should people
go if they want to keep up to date with
all the stuff you're doing at the moment
I am everywhere so my website's
adamladesmith.com I've got my video
course on there the attachment boot camp
I have books I have coaching I have a
community everything is on there I'm
also on Twitter it's at the Prometheus
I'm also on Instagram at attachment Adam
and on YouTube at Adam Lane Smith I got
400 videos on there about improving your
relationships
hell yeah Adam I appreciate you thank
you mate thank you bro if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe